it's no surprise that fans of the
witcher novels and video games were
excited by the news of the witcher tv
series but how well do netflix's
characters compare to their book and
video game counterparts and which one
caused the most controversy among fans
keep watching to find out
most fans know that dceu's superman
henry cavill plays the titular role of
the witcher however not everyone knows
that cavil is also a witcher super fan
it was his passion for the franchise
that finally convinced showrunner lauren
schmidt his rick to cast cavil as geralt
of rivia though some fans may have been
made skeptical by the news at first once
cavil first appeared on the screen there
was no question in anyone's mind that he
was perfect for the role it certainly
helped that geralt's look took a lot of
inspiration from cd projekt red's
popular video game series donning a long
white wig and yellow contact lenses
cavill's look is quite similar to geralt
from the game franchise there are a few
clear differences however for instance
geralt in the games has a distinct scar
over his left eye the video game geralt
also appears to be at least a decade
older than cavil of course witcher's age
slower than normal humans so we can
forgive the actor for his younger looks
whether fans prefer cavals geralt or
city project reds is a matter of debate
but it is clear that the witcher show
took at least some of cavill's look from
the game franchise
princess cirilla fiona ellen riannon or
siri for short is an integral character
in the witcher she is not only geralt's
ward but she is also a child of the
elder blood which gives her unbelievable
powers as fans witnessed in season two
of the witcher siri is only just
beginning to discover her full potential
and she has a long way to go before
getting her magical abilities under
control siri is played by freya allen in
the netflix series and her look tries to
closely copy the character's description
in the witcher novels in the books
siri's hair is described as ashen
colored and she has noticeably green
eyes as the witcher game franchise takes
place after the events of the books
siri's character doesn't make an
appearance in the video games until the
witcher 3 wild hunt at this point in the
timeline siri is about 18 years old
several years older than allen's
portrayal of siri in the show the
character in the witcher 3 maintains
siri's white blonde hair and distinct
green eyes though she also has a long
scar on her cheek and wears heavy eye
makeup fans of the books will know that
the scar has a story behind it one that
fans of the show will have to wait on
few are more formidable in the witcher
world than yennefer of wengerberg a
young woman who comes from nothing her
determination and strength make her one
of the most powerful and dangerous mages
on the continent yennefer is played by
anya chalotra on the show and like
yennefer of the books chalotra has long
black hair she wears contact lenses to
match the sorceress's violet eyes a
trait that marks her elven heritage we
often see yen wearing black and white
clothing the character's preferred color
scheme in the novels in the witcher
video games jennifer is first introduced
in the witcher 3 wild hunt in that
game's story geralt hasn't seen yennefer
in several years since he regains his
memory after a long bout of amnesia the
game version of yennefer is a closer
match to the character in the books her
hair is still black but it falls over
her shoulders in a mass of dark curls
she also has violet colored eyes and
wears her trademark black and white
attire the video game yennefer appears
to be some years older than chilotra yet
like geralt age doesn't mean much when
you are practically immortal whatever
fans think yennefer should look like no
one can argue that jennifer of
wengerberg is a force to be reckoned
with in any medium
guys
your harmonies were a little pitchy
gordon
you're amazing talent recognizes talent
let's go again an undeniable fan
favorite yaskir is geralt's loyal friend
and sidekick on the netflix tv series
not only does he provide comic relief
but he gives audiences a catchy earworm
with toss a coin to your witcher in
season one toss a coin to your witcher
oh valley of plenty whoa
following that hit tune was his
emotional ballad burn butcher burn in
season two which recalls epic breakup
songs like alanis more sets you ought to
know played by joey beatty yaskir's
appearance changes slightly between
seasons one and two of the witcher in
season one beatty keeps his dark brown
hair cut short and his clothes vary in
color and style when we see yes gear in
season two he now sports a long coat and
his hair is a bit longer he also wears a
stylish leather cap when he performs in
season 2 episode rodanian intelligence
yes gear is called dandelion in the
english language versions of the witcher
books and video games dandelion appears
in all three games and his looks often
change however most gamers are familiar
with dandelion's look in the witcher 3
wild hunt where he wears a colorful jerk
in with a matching pink hat and feather
he also has dark brown hair as well as a
mustache and goatee
sorceress triss marigold is a friend to
both yennefer and geralt in the witcher
like yennefer triss was taught how to
use magic at the tower of aratuza and
she later became an advisor to king
fultest of temeria in season 1 of the
witcher triss has shoulder-length curly
brown hair this is more accurate to the
character of triss in the novels who is
described as having chestnut colored
hair however triss in the video games is
a very striking redhead
this might be the reason why when we see
triss again in the witcher season 2 her
hair has been tinted red tris marigold
plays a big part in the witcher video
game series and is a primary romance
option for geralt now know more about
the battle
just
hold me
and say something nice while geralt
makes it clear that he only sees chris
as a friend in season two of the witcher
show he and triss are very intimate in
the witcher 2 assassins of kings video
game triss is also featured in the
witcher 3 wild hunt and geralt is forced
to choose between her and his long lost
love yennefer though trist may be
competition for geralt's affections in
the games in the netflix series geralt
only has eyes for yen
in season 2 of the witcher geralt
travels with siri to caremorin the home
of the witchers it was here that the
show introduces fans to vesimir the
patriarch of the group
wolf
you're home
finally vezimir leads the last of the
remaining witchers and is a father
figure to geralt he is charged with
protecting what remains of karemorin and
looking after the younger witchers sadly
their numbers are dwindling and they
currently have no way to bring more into
the fold which is a big concern for
vesimir bezimir in the show is played by
kim bodnia and it's uncanny just how
much he looks like vezimir in the
original the witcher game both have long
white hair and a walrus mustache
although vesimir of the game has a much
more stern expression the video game
version of vezimir also has small
piercing eyes that often look
disapproving while botany as vesimir has
eyes that are much more open and kind
the two characters also appear to be
about the same age
the treatment of the character eskel has
been a source of controversy for the
witcher fans eskel is one of geralt's
witcher brothers at caremorin and they
train together as boys as played by
actor basel iden benz on the netflix
show eskel has long curly hair a slim
figure and a scar on the right side of
his face although eskel in the witcher
games also has distinctive facial
scarring this is perhaps the only trait
he shares with his tv show counterpart
in the witcher and the witcher 3 wild
hunt eskel has short dark hair and a
stocky muscular build his scars are also
more prominent in the game version as
they cover his eye cheek mouth and chin
the differences between eskel in the
show and eskel in the video games goes
far beyond their physical appearances in
the season 2 episode karamorin eskel's
character is attacked by aleshi he
undergoes a transformation that turns
him into a monster and geralt is forced
to kill him the death of the character
caused an uproar with fans but perhaps
the biggest objection to the netflix
version of eskel was the changes to his
personality in the games and books eskel
is quiet kind and loyal a far cry from
the partying aggressive and hostile
witcher we meet in the show
lambert lambert what a jolly nice chap
like eskel lambert was raised by vezimir
alongside geralt at caremorin in the
second episode of the witcher season 2
he is introduced as a fun-loving
storyteller and a fierce protector he
later encourages siri to push her limits
while training by introducing her to a
challenging obstacle course although he
comes off as a bit harsh with siri at
first it's clear he has her best
interests at heart paul bullion plays
lambert in the netflix series and his
appearance is quite different from the
character in the witcher games in the
show lambert has long curly red hair and
a full beard lambert in the game
franchise has short dark brown hair a
trim beard and a scar that runs from his
hairline down his cheek lambert's
personality in the games is also quite
different from how he is portrayed in
the tv show lambert's character in the
games is much grimmer and has a
sarcastic streak what what are you doing
killing monsters
good one nevertheless lambert is a fan
favorite amongst gamers so hopefully
bullion's representation will live up to
their standards
in the witcher season 2 episode rodanian
intelligence the series introduces fans
to an intriguing new character sigismund
diekstra is the head of
spy network and an advisor to king
visamir his job is to keep tabs on the
elves and nilfgaardians who have allied
against the northern kingdoms he is
played by graham mctavish who has a bald
head a full gray beard and a muscular
frame in the video game dykstra is bald
clean-shaven and has a large build he
also appeared in the witcher 3 wild hunt
he is one of four crime syndicate
leaders in the city of novograd and
helps geralt in his search for siri
though the two are anything but friends
sorry can't let that happen
mctavish shares some of the same
physical traits as the game version of
dykstra yet there are clear differences
in how he portrays the character in the
witcher tv show dykstra is underhanded
and sly while the version of the
character in the game tends to rely on
brute force to get things done
though she only appears for a moment in
the season 2 finale of the witcher the
sorceress philippa eilhart makes quite
an impression in that short time using
the magical ability to shapeshift
philippa spends most of her time in the
form of an owl going back and forth to
relay messages between dykstra and his
elven spy contact dara actor cassie
claire plays philippa on the netflix
show she has long black hair a striking
figure and wears an elegant gown
decorated with feathers along the collar
and shoulders philippa appears in the
witcher 2 assassins of kings and the
witcher 3 wild hunt her appearance is
quite different from the character on
the tv series the game version of
philippa has long black hair that is
styled into two braids and she wears
long feathers in her hair fans of the
witcher series may notice that claire
wears two small braids at the front of
her hair which is perhaps a tribute to
the game version of philippa
the finale of the witcher season 2 ends
with a huge plot twist that leaves fans
reeling the true identity of the king of
nilfgaard amir far emery's
it turns out amir is none other than
dooney the young man who was helped by
geralt in season one fans will remember
that dooney is placed under a curse that
turns him into a porcupine man beast and
he crashes queen kalenthi's party to
claim the hand of princess pavetta when
he is attacked by the queen's soldiers
geralt steps in to defend him the curse
is broken when pavetta uses true love's
kiss to turn dooney back to his human
self dooney is the father of siri yet
what happened to him between his curse
being broken and becoming the king of
nilfgaard is still a mystery on the
netflix show amir is played by bart
edwards and his appearance is not all
that different from amir in the witcher
games both characters have long dark
hair though edward's hairstyle is wavy
and wild while amir in the witcher 3
wild hunt wears his hair slicked back
and straight the game version of amir is
also much older than the character on
the show mainly because the game's
events take place many years after the
story in the witcher books now that
amir's identity has been disclosed fans
can bet that he will have a big part to
play in the future of the witcher
netflix series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you